protein our lives are on the line we had
a lot of fun filming our Odysseus
challenge so we thought we'd do another
famous archery challenge William Tell if
you don't know who William Tell us he
shot an apple off his son's head legend
goes at least what we're gonna do that
today in real life our lives are on the
line just kidding actually they'll be
really dumb to do it for real so we're
going to be using these padded arrows
and we will be wearing face masks it's
still gonna hurt like a should we get
hit in the chest or the stomach or the
middle of the face good question is
anyone know the legend of William Tell
time firts with Jake history guys I just
remember Betty shot and Apple office son
said that's about it why no I can't move
this Apple has to be shot well I don't
know every detail but William Tell he
was a total badass dude apparently this
guy is like a face shot with a crossbow
and he assassinated this like evil Duke
starts an open Civil War Lord in a roll
of dice everybody signed a number roll
the dice for being the Sun someone just
rolled the dice for being the father if
you kill your son you become the son on
the next archery tape yeah I want to
shoot someone up wait can you can you
actually let me see let me see if I can
do
Adrian don't do it there's no accuracy
there his collarbone is split in two
places
yeah well this die roll is for the
person who will be doing the shooting
this is for William Tell five all right
Ren Ren is going to be holding someone's
life in his hands
one that's J all right Jake grab a
helmet you don't want to kill your son
you're gonna miss miss hi
don't miss lo what happens if friend
hits the Apple yeah would it be nails it
yeah what so what's the price then you
got to eat it
I flipped chairs there's no way Ren's
gonna make it all right who here thinks
Ren will make it wait a minute all right
the air on backwards can't even put the
arrow on right good luck Jake good
monogram
you know I thought you didn't even warn
me man you just went for it I said are
we ready the new shooter is Jake
I think Ren and I have a long history of
doing crazy stuff and coming out alive
main thing is just not to hit him
directly in the face yes yes yeah
Jake I will miss hi I don't think
Clint's gonna do it
everybody's been just like assassinating
the sons now we should aiming over hi
everything's closed you're right in the
face got you son
I'll be back sign this one's for you I
believe in you Clinton
that's not how useless to him
Eero there's an arrow in my cheekbone
right here dude we go my turn
get out of here you ghost I've had
pretty good luck with the archery
challenges let's see if this changes
here all right yeah
this is not gonna no one's actually
gotten this yet either to fire them not
quite sure maybe you desire maybe
Jarrett will be the true William Tell
this guy's got a broken collarbone II
can't
tell to do this things like I like it on
the other end long Adrienne he'll not be
behind us - I think so Nick did pretty
good last time so I feel I have any
one's gonna get it just know this is
definitely a likely can you don't home
to mama tonight are you right down there
left I don't do it anymore
I'm just
another boy you better close your eyes
or I'm looking for you I said airplane
overhead my face I don't know come on
Nick here we go that was actually close
that was honorably didn't kill you
though Carmichael needs to go give me
that camera boy all right the most
effective death we've seen yet come back
is the boy sorry tree is cool and all
but hey guess what we just put out a new
video on the corridor channel it's about
the world's longest lightsaber that I
somehow built and made a reality and
today we're gonna talk about some of the
effects that made it happen this I
totally lost my train of thought don't
know where I was going with that for my
protein
this whole video is about a lightsaber
that just gets longer and longer but
here's the thing
traditionally lightsabers were like the
hardest effect to do okay they were not
necessarily the hardest effect but no
one liked doing them because they were
so like time intensive but fortunately
thanks to a Video Copilot dotnet there
is a fantastic free plugin for After
Effects to do this super easily and I'm
gonna kind of break down the process for
that
so the plugin is called it's a bird so
what makes Sabre so nice and easy for
lights it reflects is that all of the
settings are automated there's only two
points that you gotta animate that base
in the tip of the lightsaber and so it
helps if you have like a actual
lightsaber to track but on a lot of
these shots we didn't even have that we
just kind of had to wing it there's
literally dozens of presets that I can
select let's go to kryptonite
what does kryptonite over so if I had a
kryptonite lightsaber it would look like
that I think we used literally like the
Mo's defaults I don't think we changed
any sayings I don't even think we
changed the color of the lightsaber
that's the lightsaber look that we were
going for and it is the default one you
start with so what's cool about this you
can adjust the glow so if I set to like
zero glow or like a million percent glow
the lightsaber itself is actually white
it's the glow that is colored I can
change the intensity of that glow to
really be really you know low I can
change the glow bias and globe spread
these are all settings that you can play
around with when you're trying to dial
in your effects and whatnot when doing a
lightsaber shot you want to have some
sort of prop that you can track
something with the base and a tip so you
can actually track the basin tip of the
shot now what you can do is you can
keyframe directly inside of the effect
and you'll notice you see how there's
actually motion blur involved as well
before you used to have to shape it with
the masks and whatnot you don't have to
do that anymore so yeah I just went
through and frame-by-frame animate the
position for all that and that's where
most of the work for this video came
from is just literally going through
frame by frame across some music let's
do a book or something another really
interesting thing about this shot is
that we actually filmed it practically
so it's a real lightsaber prop we sliced
an apple before hand put the Apple back
together
and then tossed it at the lightsaber and
I hit it out of the air like literally
just like boom and the apple just goes
falling off to the right and it's not
until it hits the ground when it finally
like comes apart and then rolls to a
stop and that's when camera like whips
down and we see it there in fact you can
actually see the other half of the Apple
kind of rolling away
it looks like I'm literally hitting a
ball with the bat rather than cutting a
ball with a lightsaber so I had an idea
I was like how can we make this look
like it's split so I literally just
duplicated my footage and then as this
going around
I literally just mess out just the Apple
and it is it wasn't even a good match
there's literally just a few points that
feathered a bit and then I took that and
I flipped it so I set the scale to
negative 100% only on the x-axis I
literally just flipped it horizontally
shifted that Apple over and I feather a
little bit look at that we have a whole
another Apple and this is what it looked
like all right so get the lightsaber
tracked in
we got the Apple added so that there's
some kisses to see with that but now we
have to have some sort of reaction
because you know you can't burn an apple
without some smoke smoke stock elements
like sparks little smoke hits a little
charge bursts you gotta add all that in
you gotta get your layers going drop in
some elements I think what did I track
here I think I tracked like a thing on
the ceiling when you're tracking your
footage you always want to track the
thing closest to where the element is
gonna be placed and the problem here is
that the element is placed in the middle
of the air there's nothing around its
that I can track so I think I check the
ceiling and that works fine and then it
looks good so that that little burst
there is actually made of three
different spark elements we got that one
we got this one and then the other one
nice thanks for watching this I know it
wasn't really too much of a tutorial but
that's because this effect is dead
simple to do and you should go make your
own lightsaber effects right now as well
so in the meantime let's go back and
watch this William Tell experiment and
see who can actually hit the Apple off
of our heads how has no one done this
yet I don't know it's hard man having a
person
[Applause]
[Music]
as a friend you go it's great
Adrian every time Adrian's been shooting
he's been he's been gone I've been doing
that all right here we go Jake this is
already verse I windows facing you're
all yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you sure look good I look really good
it hit the Apple first I didn't feel it
no that is all applicants all apple yeah
we learned that William tail must have
had a lot of boys
congratulations Adrien like it's gotta
regain my throne as archery champ huh
losing a guy with a broken collarbone
you can think of any historical
challenges that we should try next let
us know if you haven't subscribed
consider subscribing it you'll like it
make good videos while a little busting
glass blog tutorials oh yeah
oh I'll eat you later I was gonna use
that for something actually forgot what
I was gonna use it for um anyway